a nine-year-old's wish has come true
just in time for his birthday thanks to
make-a-wish southern nevada this boy is
receiving a water therapy pool and a
surprise pool party with all of his
loved ones jeremy j ford has the
heartwarming story
this is a truly once in a lifetime
opportunity for him bradley kershaft is
getting the birthday gift of his dreams
the nine-year-old has had a nervous
system disorder since he was born he's
wheelchair-bound and suffers from
increasing muscle spasms and seizures he
wants just freedom and i feel like this
pool will give him some sort of a
freedom to go in the water kick those
legs and give him some independence and
it's all thanks to make a wish southern
nevada it's an incredible day for us
we've been working on for about eight
months now and we're thrilled to be able
to give him this pool where he can start
to feel weightless and feel like any
other kid splashing around in the
southern nevada heat this summer a
therapeutic way to enjoy some rehab and
recreational time that a pool where he
could splash around and really kind of
strengthen his arms and his limbs would
be the greatest impact to bradley's life
especially on his ninth birthday
everyone that bradley loves and adores
is here jeremy j ford live local now
make a wish is a non-profit that's
devoted to granting wishes to children
with critical illnesses